♪♪
Poppy:
I still can't believe it.
We're going to fall in love with a
new little person again.
(Chuckles)
♪♪
Dr. Scott:
Just breathe.
♪♪
Man:
I'm gonna count you down from 3.
♪♪
Man:
And on 3.
And 2.
Man:
And 1.
Dr. Scott:
Breathe.
♪♪
Cameron:
I can't lie to my family anymore.
♪♪
Dr. Scott:
The second you tell your wife
that you are dying,
♪♪
your opportunity to do this is
gone.
♪♪
Dr. Scott:
You want to go say hi?
♪♪
So he has everything?
Even the memories you store
deep in your subconscious.
♪♪
Dr. Scott:
Do this with us and let life go
on for your family.
Dr. Scott:
A clean swap.
♪♪
Oh, what's going on, Cam?
I can't figure out what the
right thing is here.
-Hugo: Ah oh.
-Cam: Bee boo.
(Laughing)
Cam:
I thought I had more time, I
guess.
♪♪
Dr. Scott:
You have an opportunity here.
I'm not done. I didn't say he
could...
You're dying.
♪♪
Cam:
I feel like I've falling in love
with her for the first time again.
♪♪
I don't like this.
You think I like this?
♪♪
Being told I'm not me.
Because you're not me.
♪♪
You are not me!
Poppy:
I love you, Cameron Turner.
♪♪